people and in particular children who
overuse mouth breathing as opposed to
nasal breathing have changes in the
structure of the face that to be quite
direct makes them far more unattractive
than if they were to mouth breathe so I
arrived carrying a copy of the book Jaws
a hidden epidemic this book was written
by my colleagues at Stanford sandre Khan
and Paul Erick it also discusses the
chewing of foods as essential to mouth
and face development Sandra KH is an
expert in cranial facial function and
structure and the fact that if your
parents and you did things right you
should be able to place your entire
tongue on the roof of your mouth with
your mouth closed now I can't do that I
can but I still feel the back of my
teeth a bit chewing Foods is essential
to tooth and mouth and face development
so that's the second point so nasal
breathing good chewing hard Foods
chewing a lot on both sides of the mouth
great for cranial facial development
oral development tooth development and
tooth Health which by the way are
correlated with a number of other things
like cardiovascular health and metabolic
Health very interesting links there